um a white la times writer by the name
of gene guerrero had some thoughts about
larry elder which
uh she decided to share on on cnn and
we we've we've heard this exact line
many
times and they're pretty shameless about
it but here it is let's listen he's
essentially been running his campaign on
fox news and on right-wing media outlets
um he he's refused to talk to
large you know to non-partisan and
media outlets and to journalists who are
critical of him
has refused to answer difficult
questions often uses uh the few
interviews that he does give as an
opportunity to give a performance on on
social media you know denouncing those
journalists and um playing the the
victim um but he has been able to reach
the the minority of voters in california
who embrace his his white supremacist
world view um and you know he's he's
co-opted this line by my fellow
columnist uh from from the headline you
know calling him the black face of white
supremacy but he refuses to engage with
the actual substance of our reporting
you know the idea that he his his
views were shaped by a well-known white
supremacist named jared taylor who he
repeatedly quoted in early writings um
that he plans to reverse all of the
state's progress on immigrant rights and
racial justice um and that he poses a
very real threat to communities of color
for all of the reasons that we've
reported it in the past
just just another example of of how
white supremacy has become this doesn't
of course doesn't mean anything at all
it's this religious
it's this religious idea um this sin
that you know it's it actually goes
beyond white people
if you have the wrong ideology then
you're automatically a white supremacist
and it's important to remember this too
because um
you have to kind of adjust the equation
on the
on the uh the victim
hierarchy the victim pyramid that i've
talked about before
we know there's a a hierarchy of
victimhood on the left and uh and
there's always this jockeying for
position that goes on
and the the group at the top tends to
change over time
uh it could change even on a monthly
basis as there's this struggle to who's
gonna be the the uber victim
and as it stands right now
top of the victim of pyramid the victim
hierarchy are trans people
and specifically trans people of color
they're the very you you cannot get more
victory than that they're at the very
very top
um and then as you go as you go down the
ladder
there's really no one challenging trans
people right now for top victim spot
so they're pretty comfortable
they might not be there forever but
they're pretty comfortable at that spot
right now
um and then as you go down the ladder
for the different victim groups
that's where the positions tend to
change it gets pretty interesting
but that
said there is the ideological
qualification here which is really
important
so normally larry elder as a black man
would be uh pretty high up on the victim
hierarchy like above women
there was a time not long ago and that's
why i say things change during the metoo
movement the women had their time in the
sun as the uber victims and they were
the very top probably even above trans
uh and now they've fallen precipitously
so
you know normally you would say and we
know that on the victimhood pyramid
pyramid
criticism can only go down
okay someone who's lower on the
hierarchy as a victim cannot criticize
anyone above them
trans people at the top they can
criticize everybody
criticism can only go downhill right
um so normally
a white woman
attacking a black man in this way would
not be acceptable
but
that's where the ideological
qualification comes in because he's a
conservative none of this counts
conservatives are at the very very very
bottom of the ladder and once you get
down there races identity none of that
matters
[Music]
they're all white supremacists they're
all nazis that's all
so that's the way that's the way this uh
that equation works
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated